please proceed governor
obama
sir sir
i don't even know what i'm doing sir
welcome everybody we're joining day four
of the kyle rittenhouse trial in
progress
um there's a ton to talk about including
the juror that was dismissed yesterday
um
or today
since yesterday uh because of a joke
they made about jacob blake if you can
imagine which is just i mean this this
this trial is just disgusting so we're
gonna get to all of that um also people
have asked me to talk about the insane
report on
tim poole getting covet and joe rogan
offering to pay for his ivermectin and
stuff but let's just let's just jump
right into this now because it is
ongoing i assume that they're going to
take one more break before the end it's
an hour um
they're in central time
let's listen
in their words there were people trying
to break into the stella and light it on
fire
somebody had pointed a gun at them
and
the cops weren't around
so we headed across the
other car source facility
across the way into the burned out cars
and
there were three to four subjects
breaking out windows on the stella
and
just milling around over there
and once we got to
within a hundred yards of them
i believe it was colette yelled out at
them they turned and saw us and they ran
off
you were one of the people along with
dustin cleth that went over there that's
correct who else went with you
i want to say that
kyle was with us and
one of the protesters who had
told us about it
so
this is a volunteer enforcer that we're
hearing from out or fire start or
anything like this but what what gave
you
the right
to go around and police
that area
um well they remember is the community
that asked us to go help them
who who uh these four protesters
well those you characterized as folks
walking with fire extinguishers were
they from the stella
they came from that direction
were they employed by the stella
i didn't ask
you
is it fair to say you heard a report
that somebody was up to no good and you
decided to head over there and stop it
correct other than that you don't know
anything more about what was going on
there's a vigilante
and these people you saw milling about
at the stella
do you know who they were
um one was a tall this one was fairly
tall the rest of the people seemed about
average height or shorter
beyond that description of their height
do you know anything else about them no
we didn't get that close don't know
where they came from no don't know their
names nope you don't know where they are
afterwards
no
don't know what their affiliation if any
was with the stella
right i would assume they weren't
affiliated with the stella
i would assume somebody breaking the
cell's windows is probably not i agree
with that but my point is is
you're making an assumption
correct
with less than perfect information
assuming correct
you mentioned a fire uh at the saint
james was that the saint james church
um
[Music]
this church right here
now can you just uh put your pointer
back up right where you were doing this
is a satellite photograph of kenosha
that's a little older there's a building
that you're pointing at right now on the
night of august 25th 2020 that building
wasn't standing anymore was it
no there was a pilot there's a little
rubble right here but there's another
building right in there okay uh the
church itself is actually on the other
end of the the north end of the block
along 58th street is that right that is
correct okay when you said you mentioned
something about a fire or somebody
trying to start a fire at that location
can you tell us more about that
um yes the same
individuals that told us about the
stella showed up again
and they described
a female two males trying to light a
fire at the church
what did you do
um we
kind of just walked around
the street to kind of look around there
when we got there
we could see somebody on the front of
the church they saw us they ran off
did you see anything more than that one
person
uh no
did you see what that person was doing
no
did you see a fire no did you put out a
fire no
what do you guys think kyle rittenhouse
is writing down during this testimony at
8 o'clock to 9 30 or 10 o'clock period
of time and you've described a couple of
things the stella incident the st james
incident so
beyond that
what other things were you doing in that
period of time we were walking
down to 63rd to check it out
at that point we had figured out that
the folks that said they were going to
stay there no longer stayed there
so
once he's into
two at a time people are going down
there to check on it
then they would go over the ultimate
check on the guys over there see what
they were doing
and then they were protecting guys come
on
we've seen some photos and videos of the
ultimate gas station
would it be fair to say that there were
people protecting that location that
were similar to your group you know
armed with long rifles things like that
that is correct
and you mentioned that
the whatever these vans were with these
folks with melee weapons at 63rd
at some point in the evening you found
out they weren't there anymore that is
correct
i want to ask more specifically about
that was that something that you
personally found out or you heard from
someone else
um
i kind of just heard it through
discussion
that there was nobody down there anymore
when you heard that
how many
people were in your group guarding the
59th street location at that point
it would have been around seven or eight
and you said you would send groups of
two people at a time to go down to 63rd
that's correct were you ever one of
those folks yes was the defendant yes
what was going on when you went down
there oh when we went down that way
there was nobody down there
um a couple of the folks that had been
down there initially
had moved over to the ultimate
that seemed to be where they had kind of
ganged up with the folks with the melee
stuff had kind of
okay so i want to make sure i'm
understanding you you said a couple of
the folks that were at the 63rd street
car source initially
wound up going over the ultimate gas
station that is correct were those folks
that came in those vans
um
one of them came at the same time the
vans did okay
so the one
one of the people that came at the same
time
as the vans did wand up at ultimate gas
that is correct
and it sounds like there may have been
more more than just one person from 63rd
that wound up at ultimate gas there was
one other guy that was with him when we
showed up okay
so
is it fair to say that
speaking for you personally mr bulch
you felt like it was part of your
responsibility to not only guard the
59th street car source but also the 63rd
street car source that is correct which
is why you were and other folks were
going down there to check on it that's
correct okay
so i want to continue talking about that
eight o'clock to 9 30 or 10 o'clock
period we've talked about a few things
other than that
what else was were you doing during that
period of time um mostly we were just
kind of talking to people when they
would walk by
um
we didn't really have any negative
encounters during that period of time
um you'd get the occasional person
wanting to have a debate and whatnot but
most of it was just
walking down the 63rd somebody coming
saying somebody's trying to light
something on fire
go check it out come back
watch it check it out like they're cops
you guys know right i mean vigilantes so
now uh you've mentioned there was a time
when the police started to move the
protesters in your direction and i think
you said earlier that was around 9 30 or
10 o'clock
this is correct okay tell us about that
um as soon as
they started pushing the protesters we
started getting
the less
i guess the people who weren't intending
on participating in a riot
i should say started kind of drifting
down towards us
um
there were some
they were shouting
insulted us
i got the feeling this guy sees himself
almost like a law enforcement witness
even though he's just a vigilante i
spent the large majority of that time
trying to calm people down
and just keep on moving down the street
then we started encountering people who
were more and more aggressive
and
the cops
would push them then they would back off
they'd come back and push them again
and they would push them further south
each time or yeah that's south
when you describe these interactions
with the people walking past
was the defendant present for any of
that he had one exchange that i saw
who was that with
just some
i don't know why the audio cut
he said i love you too ma'am
um
the hell you mentioned earlier
that there was some sort of report of
someone in a red shirt something's up
with this guy right that was a weird
kind of
thing there sort of incident i think i
heard you mention that yes
we now know with the benefit of
hindsight who joseph rosenbaum was and
we've seen photographs of him in a red
shirt and a bald head
let me start by asking
whatever report you heard
regarding mr rosenbaum at that
particular time you did you ever see him
at that time
um i had seen someone fitting the
description kind of milling in and out
of the groups that were coming through
um every time he was around the groups
when now that i know who joseph
rosenbaum was and confirmed who he
was and stuff um
he was not organic with the protesters
what do you mean by that they didn't
seem comfortable with his presence
or the people that were with him
why are you red uh he had a male and a
female that were with him
pretty much consistently throughout the
night
so you saw those folks together yes him
and the male and the female did you ever
see them speaking to one another um
the male and the female yes
but as far as them talking to him
directly no
so you never saw mr rosenbaum talk to
that male or female no and you never saw
the male and female talk what's funny is
this seems like a defense witness but
it's a prosecution witness and i'm
curious where they're going with this
proximity to one another so you're
making some sort of assumption that they
had some sort of association is that
fair to say
um i saw them in close proximity with
each other several times which led to
that assumption okay
tell us about the first time that you
observed mr rosenbaum um the first time
he was just
getting aggravated with someone in the
crowd
and
the protesters were trying to like
separate him from whoever that was
and
hasn't alex jones vibe to him for sure
well
and one of the things that stood out to
me was the tall male that was with him
had a handgun in his hand
with the finger on the trigger
pointed down to the ground
now you had an ar-15 this is correct and
you had your hand on the
butt of that ar-15 no
at no point
hand on the grip with the fingers
straight forward along the side of the
receiver i i misspoke when i said butt i
mean i the the grip the pistol grip of
the ar-15 you had your hand on that with
your your finger not on the trigger but
within close proximity that is correct
okay and this individual had a handgun
right with his finger on the trigger
this is correct and that caused you to
be concerned of some sort of
what
well
incredible
not to put your finger on the trigger
unless you're ready to shoot
um
the way he was holding it
had anybody bumped into him or him
tripped and fell
he would have been sitting around often
who knows what
so i just saw it as unsafe
and the potential for some sort of
tragic accident
correct or he was prepared for something
did you ever see him point that gun at
anyone um no did you ever see him fire
that gun
no
and obviously you had
a gun that was bigger and more powerful
than his fair to say this is fair to say
and you're familiar with ar-15s that's
correct how long had you owned your
ar-15 since 2012.
so eight years yes and over that period
of time how many times had you fired
your ar-15
by august of 2020 i probably had
somewhere close to 10 to 15 000 rounds
through it
and what type of ammo what did it take
what caliber 556.
and are you familiar with the term full
metal jacket this is correct and is that
the type of ammo you would use yes or no
and can you uh as a military former
infantryman in the army who's fired 10
to 15 000 rounds can you tell us a
little bit about what full metal jacket
our
bullets are
um fmga full metal jacket bullets are
just a solid copper jacket around a lead
core
nothing really particularly special
about it i need to drink
more dangerous than any other type of
ammunition
um in the state of wisconsin you're not
allowed to hunt with full metal jacket
ammunition
do you know why that is
penetration
over penetration
what is that it's almost weird to be
asking this guy
questions of this sort hollow points are
designed to hit the target and expand
and transfer the energy
a full metal jacket's not designed to do
that so
depending on what it hits it can just
sail right on through
so it's fair to say that a full metal
jacket round fired from an ar-15 has the
potential for hitting
whatever it's shot at say a deer for
example and going through that and
continuing on to something down the line
it can as opposed to a hollow point
which typically hits a deer for example
and then stops
yes
and
is it fair to say in your experience
that a glock handgun like you had that
night is often loaded with hollow-point
ammunition and a ar-15 is often loaded
with full metal jacket ammunition
it depends on what you're doing with it
is that what you typically would do i
tend to run full metal jackets yes in
the in the air 50 in the air 15. what
about your glock
hollow points
and why is that
um my air 15 i mostly use it for target
and competition shooting
competition block is more for
personal defense
loading a handgun like a glock with
hollow point ammunition
is what you would consider to be uh the
better choice for self-defense
yeah for concealed carry absolutely
what about for open carry
for open carry it would be the same
thing for a glock handgun
when you've fired your old guy ar-15 10
to 15 000 rounds of full metal jacket
ammunition through there um what is the
furthest distance of target that you've
hit with that 500 yards so it's a weapon
that's capable of shooting a full metal
jacket round and hitting a target 500
yards away
it's maximum it's so funny a lot of
people just joining are like is this an
expert witness on firearms like no no
it's not i don't even know why they're
doing this
now sir you're turning purple out
mr rosenbaum
and your observations of him and i think
you described something out in the
street with some other protesters or he
yelled
oh boy
please proceed governor
every time i encountered joseph
rosenbaum he was hyper aggressive
and acting out in a violent manner
and we say violent manner you saw him
hitting punching kicking
always having to be restrained by
someone okay
and i i understand that did you ever see
him hit anyone i the crowd was pretty
good about getting in between him and
whoever it was if he landed a blow i
didn't see it the answer would be no but
he definitely wanted to
well now you have no idea do you what
was going on in mr rosenbaum's head no
you'd never met him before that night no
okay so let's just keep to your
observations if we can how tall are you
five nine how tall was mr rosemont
five four five three
so much shorter and smaller than you yes
sir
um now i know you want to talk about
what you believe he was intending to do
but my question to you was did you ever
actually see him
hit anyone
no did you ever actually see him
kick anyone
no did you ever actually see him with a
weapon in his hand
no did you ever actually see him cause
any physical injury to anyone that night
i saw him attempt to do it on a couple
occasions
that was not my question mr bulch did
you ever
excuse me
it was my impression he was answering
your question he wasn't
you you'd agree with me
pardon me it's not cross-examination
he's supposed to ask open-ended
questions he was answering
i it was my impression that the witness
had not completed his answer i apologize
i'll try to stop uh uh jumping in a
little too soon mr bulge um did you ever
see
the defendant
actually physically in er sorry mr
rosenbaum did you ever actually see mr
rosenbaum
physically injure anyone that night no
did you personally
have any interactions with mr rosenbaum
i got between him and colette at one
point and then
he
threatened me and the defendant
the time you described where you and you
got in between him and dustin collette
between mr rosenbaum and dustin collect
was the defendant present for that
uh it immediately preceded him
threatening me in calron house
so was the defendant present for that
yes
tell us about that
um colette had stopped him from putting
something starting something on fire
there's
a video of it
and
i'm sick of the judge too guys we're
going to talk about it at the break
there's actually a lot going on behind
the scenes to discuss stopped doing that
i turned and had an exchange with one of
the protesters
and
i kind of explained to that protester
hey
you know i get it get what you're trying
to do but like not this
and when i turned around
rosenbaum was right there in front of my
face
yelling and screaming
and
i said dude back up just chill
i don't know what your problem is and
you get
oh boy i think they're they're bleeping
uh swears right
you said that as well the defendant was
there
so yes
and as far as you could tell the
defendant was close enough to hear what
mr rosenbaum said that is correct
now when this conversation occurred were
you wearing your ar-15 uh in front of
slung in front of your body
that is correct did mr rosenbaum ever
reach for it
he didn't try did he touch the question
no you had your glock pistol on your hip
correct that's correct did he ever reach
for that no did he ever touch that no
did he ever touch you
no
and at that point could you see
that mr rosenbaum had no weapons of any
kind
he had a bag full of
what looked to be chemicals to me
him in his hand the guy with the glock
with a handgun behind him
and a female with a backpack that was
what i can consider rosenbaum having
with him okay so a couple things first
of all uh this bag this plastic bag yes
was it something that you could see
inside it was a clear hospital type bag
it had containers but i couldn't really
tell what the containers were
i made the assumption at the time and
told the fbi the same thing that i
thought it was for making molotov
cocktails
and was that actually true
um
i saw this a similar bag later in the
night that didn't contain those
chemicals so
the assumption that
did not
when you say you saw a similar bag in
the night what you mean correct me if
i'm wrong is after the defendant
shot mr rosenbaum
in that incident mr rosenbaum threw that
same and we can see from the videos he
throws that same bag
at the defendant and it is left lying on
the ground of the 63rd street car source
you're aware of that from all the videos
correct
did you go
to that 63rd street car source
after the defendant killed joseph
rosenbaum
yes did you see
that plastic bag laying on the ground
yes did you look inside of it yes did it
have any sort of molotov cocktail
no it had some
like
bottles that would be for soap
but
i'd seen plenty of people carrying those
around during the protest so i had no
idea what was actually contained within
them oh and when you say you see you've
seen a lot of people carrying
bottles this is like the exact type of
guy where i
he why
the idea that he's walking around with
multiple weapons is scary i wouldn't
want to be anywhere near this guy with
weapons at any time was caring did you
see any chemicals that could be used to
start any sort of
tear gas or explosion or fire or
anything along those lines
i didn't really so much just look into
it as i kind of picked it up and kind of
tossed it back on the ground
but it didn't appear to be any sort of
lighter fluid or anything like that in
there
did you see anything in that bag
that you would construe as harmful or
dangerous
no
in fact you felt safe enough to walk up
to it pick it up and look at it fair
that's fair
so getting back to this
incident where the defendant is or the
mr rosenbaum sir it was shampoo not baby
shampoo can be extremely irritating to
the eyes
that are close by
as we sit here today do you now know who
those folks were
um no i don't okay
did those that male and female that
you're talking about did they say
anything to you
no the male always just had kind of a
grin on his face the whole time
um like he was kind of enjoying all the
violence and shenanigans as was going on
right this guy wasn't enjoying the
violence and shenanigans he hates
violence and shenanigans anything to the
defendant i never saw him speak to the
defendant did you see the female speak
to you at any point no did you see her
speak to the defendant no did either one
of them do anything threatening towards
you no did either one do anything
threatening towards the defendant no
you've described a
series of events that occurred
he hates violence so much he had
multiple guns some with hollow points
and some with full metal jack i know
rock is when the police started pushing
protesters by
and i think you said it there were times
when the protesters would come back and
then be pushed back back and forth is
that fair to say that's fair to say
would you mind using that pointer laser
pointer again um and point out the
the 59th street car source please
and just for the benefit of the jury
when you talk about the police moving
the protesters uh out on the street
would you agree with me that they're
being the
police are pushing people south
on sheridan uh from 58th to 59th and
eventually down south to 60th that is
correct and then you've described
times when the police would pull back
would they pull back north of 59th
yes
so the protesters would be cleared from
your area but then allowed to come back
in front of you and back and forth yes
okay
um
when those
movements would occur i know you've
described a little bit about the
interactions with the folks on the
street
in general
how would you say the attitude was of
the people on the street towards you and
your group
most of them seemed indifferent
when you say most of them were there
others that didn't seem indifferent
there were some that either
seemed really angry about us being there
and then there were other peoples that
seemed like
they were kind of happy to just stand
around and talk to us
do you remember there being issues with
the laser pointers
i do remember them calling out about
people on the roof pointing laser
pointers at them
and during that exchange with the person
somebody in the crowd actually pulls out
a laser pointer and started doing the
same thing
and
at that point to me it was kind of null
because
who's pointing the laser pointer did you
have any sort of laser
sight on your gun that would illuminate
a target no
do you know who it was up on the roof
who was doing anything like that no idea
who had that up there
they're rough
i like them
do you recall
speaking with a individual who was
taking video for a
news source or a media online source
called the rundown live
i remember him coming into the car
source area
but we didn't it wasn't so much as a
formal interview as he was just standing
around talking to us
do you remember
uh him speaking to you and the defendant
uh
when that dumpster fire occurred out in
front of your location now that's a
literal dumpster fire he's not referring
to the entire spectacle
staying on your property as opposed to
going out in the street yes that's
something you heard yes
what did you think about that
um we had protesters coming on the car
sores
um by this point we're already going out
and like people were getting knocked
down in the street
we were already going out in the street
dragging them out of the street making
sure they were okay
he
seemed to be pretty
he seemed to want to keep us out of the
street as much as possible
but
by that point there really was no
declination between what was car source
and what was the street
well you knew where the property line
was yes
um but
i'm i understand you
wanting to maybe go out and help people
and things like that but
did you interpret that message or did
you think to yourself
we can stay here and protect this
property but it's not our job to go out
there and police the neighborhood did
that thought ever occur to you not
really no no okay so you felt like
you
were free to go out and
confront people that you felt were doing
things wrong
no
help me understand that then
um
it wasn't so much as though
i'm gonna go out there and confront
people because i can
it was if somebody from the crowd asked
us to go help them we would
okay so
if you're invited right but you're you
weren't
going to just
rush into a situation when you're
uninvited and try and
that's correct
forgive me if i've already asked this
but i'm trying to keep the timing
straight here
we've talked about your arrival at the
59th street car source at around 8pm
when you first got there at that time
was there
other folks that were supposed to be
stationed at the 63rd street car source
um no
so when when was it that you learned
that the
group that was supposed to be at 63rd
street
40 minutes ago
and this is uh
uh how much longer do you expect this
particular examination
to last of this witness in total
well or about this particular issue
well it's been a lengthy discussion and
i'm just wondering where we're getting
he wants if i could just finish this
question i'll jump forward i'm sorry i
just i may have missed the answer
earlier and i apologize if i've already
asked this um do you remember when it
was that you first learned that the
judge's folks that were supposed to be
at 63rd weren't there anymore what time
of the day or evening
it would have been about an hour after
we actually got to the 59th street
so i think you said you first got there
eight so maybe nine nine okay
now
you've mentioned you
had an interaction with mr rosenbaum yes
was that at the 59th street location yes
after that
did you have any other interactions with
him that night um we encountered
him hit and missed throughout the night
but he never like approached us again
that i saw
and he tried to engage us
but you saw him around yes
what were your impressions of him when
you saw him on those other times no he
was in the middle of them trying to
light things on fire smashing anything
he could
um
in general he was just
being aggressive to the other guys down
at the ultimate
the protesters were getting
pretty upset with him being around
they were very quick to let us know
throughout the night hey that guy's not
with us that guy's not with us
don't be mad at us and like hey we get
it we've already dealt with him before
and
that was just the general vibe from him
throughout the night
so you mentioned that you saw him
starting things on fire when did you see
that um a couple more dumpsters
um they tried to light a road sign on
fire that he was a part of that how do
you light metal on fire
just random little things do you know if
the defendant saw any of that
it's possible the defendant was close by
when all this was going on
when you say mr rosenbaum was trying to
start some other dumpsters on fire where
was that at
throughout the street all up and down
59th
did he ever take any uh or was involved
in uh any of the um dumpsters at
ultimate gas being started on fire if
you if you know i
do believe talking to people after the
fact that he was but i couldn't confirm
that myself okay and again i'm not
interested in what other people think or
even what you've seen i'm that
particular night and i know it's hard to
pretend you haven't seen any other
videos in the last year but i'm trying
to focus in on what you actually
remember that night what you saw that
night do you remember seeing
mr rosenbaum
actually start any of those dumpsters on
fire no
do you remember actually seeing him
start that street sign on fire yes where
was that at that would have been
the protesters have been pushed a little
bit south of us at that point
oh where's the button
so i know a lot of people want me to
talk about the dismissed juror we're
going to talk about all of it there's
going to be a breakup coming uh i'm
going to thank everybody who's been
supporting the stream we're going to do
it all but we do want to stay with this
for now
this is the prosecution questioning
prosecution right in there
and so you're pointing to a location on
sheridan road just north of 60th that's
correct and when you say mr falch have
you ever seen metal on fire yes and what
happened then um they tried to light it
on fire it wouldn't go so they kicked it
over oh it wouldn't go okay when do we
you know when you say a
road closed sign can you describe what
that looks like those are sometimes it
was one of those big metal oh it was
metal okay you know the ones that are
portable that they can put in front of a
road to stop it to close it real quick
so about as
quiet as the witness stand is
and again you so they tried to start on
a fire but they couldn't yeah so they
just knocked it over
other than that did you see mr rosenbaum
try and start any other fires
not after that no you said i think you
said he was trying to see yeah you're
just joining us the judge recently said
how much longer is this questioning
going to be the car source area
he was throwing rocks at buildings along
the street
he was having a pretty good time
did you ever see him throw any sort of
tear gas or a gas container or anything
along those lines
i never saw him personally through
anything like that
when you say he was throwing away he had
a bag which could have contained a
jewish space laser did you see the laser
no attached
did you see those rocks hit anyone
no i didn't hit anymore what action if
any did you take after seeing the
defendant throw rocks at your group
i'm sorry with mr rosenbaum
um we didn't really take any action
um by that point the protesters were
also
pretty done with people doing that
so they were policing them as well
did you feel like
all right we are going to squeeze in a
short break we'll continue tomorrow all
right we are not going to squeeze up in
a break let's go over here straight is
that right that is correct and i know
you said that there was some back and
forth did there come a time in which the
line of police vehicles kind of
finalized and stayed at 60th yes
when that happened were you still at the
59th street location that is correct
after the police had pushed all the
protesters
south of 60th
was there any further
risk of danger to the 59th street car
source location
um we were unaware of if or when the
police were going to pull back again
so we did leave people there guys there
were policing if the police hadn't
pulled back if they'd stayed at that
60th street line and kept the protesters
south of 60th would there have been any
further risk of danger to the 59th
street location
after the police pushed the protesters
south of 60th
was there any
damage done at all after that to the
59th street location not that i'm aware
of were there any protesters around even
trying to cause any damage to that
location uh no most the protesters that
were still up at 59th with us were just
standing around talking
after the
okay so
the police
we
i understand you may not have known at
the time but it turned out that they
established that line at 60th and pretty
much kept it there is that fair to say
that's fair to say did you ever
once that happened did you ever walk
through that line heading south and
sheriff yes
who was with you when you did that
um jason lickowski kyle rittenhouse
and dustin colette was supposed to be
with us
when he said he was supposed to be what
happened
um
once we got across the line i turned
around and didn't see him
where did you go um from there i
got mixed up in the crowd
i ran across the ultimate went inside
there
and came back and started looking for
the defendant
was this the time where the
daily caller reporter richie
mcginnis was following you we had passed
mr mcginnis before we crossed the police
line south of 60th
so
you're aware of this video of richie
mcginnis interviewing the defendant and
then you and the defendant walking south
on sheridan through the police line with
mr mcginnis with you is that right is
that the time you're talking about yes
and you said there was someone else uh
mr lukowski with you yes
is he do you know is he pictured in that
video you see him following in behind us
i do believe okay
now we watched that video earlier today
there is a time in which
you
uh encounter some folks with some fire
extinguishers do you remember that
no i don't remember that
once you passed 60th
uh and just so we're clear you were
walking on the west side of uh sheridan
road correct south of 60th um richie
mcginnis is there uh recording correct
yes
tell us what you did after that point
um once we got through 60th we kind of
paused on the north side of 60th they
were throwing rocks at the cops
and
once they saw us there
they stopped throwing they kind of
shifted where they were throwing the
rocks
at the cops immediately right next to us
to a little further down
we walked across
and once we entered the crowd
uh the defendant started asking people
if they needed any first aid i was doing
the same
and
walking through past aired an
indeterminate we'll go back over here
it's a generally better stream yeah if
we kind of paused on the north side of
60th they were throwing rocks at the
cops
and
once they saw us there
they stopped throwing they kind of
shifted where they were throwing the
rocks at the cops immediately right next
to us to a little further down
we walked across
and once we entered the crowd
the defendant started asking people if
they needed any first aid i was doing
the same
and
walking through past air at an
indeterminate time i lost track of the
defendant
had you discussed with the defendant
what your plan was once you cross that
police line we were gonna check and see
if anybody needed first aid then go down
to 63rd and make sure nobody was
destroying it
and
i'm not sure if the defendant was there
when i said it but me and lakowsky had
agreed that
if we got separated we would go back to
59th
did you have any specific instructions
for the defendant
when you were heading out in that
location
um yeah it was just stay close don't get
separated and
see if anybody's hurt
you also told him
to keep his mouth shut and not engage
with people correct
um i told several individuals at 59th
street that including the defendant
i believe i told him not to respond the
way he was to certain people
what do you mean the way he was um
that goes back to earlier in the night
when he said i love you too man that's
when i told him hey don't
say that
don't even respond why not
just because
it's
it can cause somebody to escalate the
situation if they feel like you're
making fun of them a little bit
so it just wasn't needed
so the plan once you cross 60th is stay
together but if you get separated go
back correct
and try not to engage correct
and you said there came a time in which
you
lost track of the defendant this is
correct how did that happen
um
got lost in the crowd
i had a female protester
approach me and
started to try to get into a pro-gun
anti-gun exchange
from there i went inside to see if he
went to the ultimate kidney gap any
snacks
when i came back out i encountered more
individuals protecting the property i
talked to them
i assumed at the time he wasn't
that he wasn't over there anymore
and i started to make my way back north
to 59th
can we please uh play exhibit number 17.
i can't even imagine what the cross
examinations need to turn on the tvs
again
how soon does the judge ask how much
longer what do you guys think
thanks to bone master n neptune and
belly hair designs for the twitch prime
service really appreciate it
also thanks to polo dell and aj skorpia
for the twitch prime subscriptions
and thanks to mariah liverpool for
signing up on my website joinpackman.com
really appreciate the support we've been
doing daily coverage of the
trial in addition to the podcast
got some nice messages from people
thanks for doing it
we are going to look at the dismissal of
the
juror that took place yesterday
also thanks to iri man
[Applause]
you guys are kind of like
medics who are packing yeah right
but he's an emt
i got you i'm just kind of protecting
the grass i was your certified mt yeah
got you and you work as an emt normally
well
man
just like the culture gap here
[Applause]
medic coming through oh my god
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is so insane
pause the video right there did you see
yourself in that video yes
and correct me if i'm wrong but it
appears that you uh are
a little bit ahead of mr rittenhouse in
this video but then you start walking
east
across sheridan road correct okay and in
that direction is the ultimate gas
station yes
do you remember where you went after
that that's the point at which i went
inside the gas station
and then came back out
i thought i heard you say that the
purpose of going across the police lines
was to see if people are hurt and to go
check on the 63rd street location that
is correct
help me understand how does going to the
ultimate gas station and going inside
fit in with that
because there were other people at the
ultimate gas station
i don't understand with that
to go over there to see if they're hurt
too
oh i see so you went over there to see
if those people needed help yes did you
go inside the ultimate gas station yes
and i think you said at one point you
were gonna get a snack for yourself
did you know
at that point that you were leaving
the defendant no
i got comments what did you expect he
was gonna do at that point i
thought he was following me
how long was it before you realized he
hadn't followed you uh by the time i got
across the street
what did you do then i continued on to
the ultimate gas station
and talked to some of the guys there
turned around he wasn't around he should
ask what snacks he got and went inside
inside the gas station
why didn't you go looking for the
defendant um i assumed that he had went
inside the gas station as well
and then when you looked inside did you
see him no
so where did you look for him then back
outside the gas station
in the gas station lot yes and this is a
time in the evening when there are a lot
of people in that lot this is correct
did you find him no
so if he's not inside the gas station
and he's not in the lot did you go out
around the area looking for him i walked
on the outside of the crowd and tried to
look for him and then i decided to head
north to 59th why is that
that's where i told lukowski we should
go
do you know where jason lakowsky was at
this point in the video that we just
paused at um
he was behind richard mcginnis in this
and when you walked across sheridan to
the east uh do you know where mr
lakowsky went no idea when is the next
time you saw mr lakowsky um after the
shootings happened
so when you went back when you left
ultimate gas and headed back to 59th
street did you see mr lakowsky at that
point
no did he return to 59th street while
you were back there i never made it back
to 59th street why is that the shooting
started okay and we'll get to that in a
moment so
you haven't even gotten to this your
testimony is that as we're watching this
video now which has been taken by richie
mcginnis and we see the defendant right
there that jason lakowski is somewhere
uh
close by he should be okay
can we continue to play the video please
let us know if you see mr lakowsky okay
[Applause]
i think someone's got some medical weed
i'll tell you that
please proceed
[Laughter]
oh
i want to stop it there that wasn't me
moving
i'm not muting anything do you see jason
lukowski at any point in this video
no but the camera never panned to the
rear either sure i understand i'm just
asking if you saw okay fair enough
so you indicated that you went over to
the ultimate gas and then eventually
back to 59th
i headed towards 59
when is the the next time
after what we just saw here when is the
next time you saw the defendant that
night i didn't see him again that night
at all
outside of a picture now
all right i would like to play
exhibit number
18
at that uh time stamp i indicated please
why is this guy rolling his eyes at the
mention of an exhibit
[Music]
thanks to ross patton ross thanks for
signing up on my website i appreciate
that
ross using the code felony 21 appreciate
that very much
[Music]
this has a circus atmosphere to it
absolutely
we're gonna get to that i assume they'll
take a break at some point
anybody know how late they've been going
east coast time
is there an hour earlier
540 okay that makes sense
[Music]
10 seconds i we missed a little bit of
the beginning of this a little bit
further yeah let's play there please
and we'll see how this uh
goes since everyone seems to be peaceful
now with the militia
i'm not muting just remember that
pause that for a second um you saw
yourself in that video
you mentioned that the police decided to
gas something or something or other i
didn't quite catch at all what what were
you talking about there i was talking
about when they gas the 59th street
location
when you say they you mean the police
yes when did that happen
um in the video where they show them
throwing me in the defendant a bottle of
water
it's like immediately preceding that
so why do you know what was going on
that caused the police um they saw that
we had protesters standing in it amongst
us
and it seemed like they didn't care for
that too much okay
were you affected by that gas yes also
well i'd already been hitting hit with a
some sort of gas bomb from
the protest crowd
and then that's when the gas hit the
area so i had to go inside and sit down
for a couple of minutes
when you say gas is this like a tear gas
type thing tear gas yeah okay what
physical effect did that have on you
um i couldn't breathe for a good minute
and a half there
solidly
once i got in sat down
the defendant helped me out with that um
i was okay
for the days after i really couldn't
talk too well
what did the defendant do to help you
uh kept shoveling water at me
so
did he give you any sort of medicine or
anything like that
medicine so when you're talking about
the police gassing things that's what
you're referring to yes and then you
talk about something about the emt
having to guard the emt or something
like that yes what did you mean by that
i said that's i was referring to me
watching the defendant
so we're going to take a break but you
won't miss anything we'll continue to
monitor you sort of will actually let's
go over here some snacks or whatever and
then i think you actually said earlier
you spoke to some of the folks that were
where are we
i'm trying to
set the time frame for the jury but the
ultimate relevance here on her is that
this this witness is
indicating that his role was to protect
the defendant that night and he's
obviously not with the defendant at this
moment
okay let me just switch to the perceived
need for protection south of 60th street
by
at least this individual is close to
that what relevance would his
perception because they're part of the
same group and he's taken this
responsibility and now they're in an
area where there's a perceived need to
protect the defendant well why don't we
take a break um
please don't talk about the case during
the break
uh read watch less known account of the
trial uh we'll see about uh
uh five after
oh boy
what pardon me
yeah you're right we're going she's
correct as i've complained about that
clock before we're going to start at the
four o'clock on of actual time and pay
no attention to that clock which you
won't be able to see from the drawing
room anyway
do not look at the clock in this room
from the other room okay all right i
invite you to stay with us this is going
to be a very short break only 13 minutes
um this is the pr oh boy everybody
having a grand old time this is the
prosecution
interviewing another sort of vigilante
type guy
um who was with kyle rittenhouse for
much of the day
i do want to get this is maybe one of
the most interesting things that
happened yesterday
a juror was dismissed for making a joke
about jacob blake
who was uh the sort of impetus for the
entire fact that these protests were
going on in kenosha okay this was
yesterday uh okay i the reason i asked
you to calm down was um
there was a uh
i was told that while you were being
escorted to the car the other day
that you
began to tell a joke
about the shooting of jacob blake
and i wanted to see if is that accurate
or not not it is
okay
um
are you comfortable repeating what the
joke was or do you want to just leave it
alone
i i'm going to tell you that
i i spoke about um
well i guess i'll hear from mr uh did
you want to finish what you were saying
i will tell you
i will tell you that
um i've talked quite a bit about
public confidence in the outcome of the
trial yeah there's already very little
thanks to this guy
and regardless of whether
the
issue is as grave as you presented it in
terms of
inner feelings
uh
it's clear that the appearance of bias
is present
and it would seriously undermine the the
outcome of the case
so that in itself would be sufficient
cause for discharge but if you want to
expand on that you're welcome to no you
are
did you want to say anything defense
if number seven's unwilling to to repeat
it
what it was um i think we're at a
disadvantage
and i suppose his unwillingness
can be taken in the worst light
so
based on the unwillingness at this point
the defense considers it a disadvantage
if they remove a guy who jokes about the
death of jacob blake tells you a lot
about
i mean that's accurate it's crazy but
that's accurate he's like listen we'd
love to have the guy joking about the
death of jacob blake here on the jury
but we're sort of at a disadvantage if
they don't tell us what the joke is i
think it's probably the proper course
okay all right i think uh the best thing
under the circumstances i'm going to
dismiss you from the jury sir
and we do thank you for taking the time
to come down here
thank you sir you can't ask that
question
i have not
i have not stated that you have
uh
it's not you know one of the things that
i have to do when i have to make
judgments
i try to confine my judgments to the
things i have to judge and not
forming opinions about other people
other than that
so i don't want to get into that
the point i'm making is that the public
needs to be confident that this is a
fair trial
and i think even at the at the very most
it was a it was bad judgment
to tell a joke of that nature
okay so that's
okay so you're gone um yeah that's the
end uh that's the end for that uh juror
um that'll be the end there
um so we're standing by for the
resumption glad to have everybody here i
i really do appreciate everybody who's
been here all week uh today is day four
sort of day three this is they're in a
break this is not live folks this is not
live so you're not missing anything as
soon as they resume believe me i'm gonna
bring it to you
um i wanna say thanks to angel's kid as
well as dan's news and mazzik for
following for subscribing via twitch
prime i really appreciate that uh
appreciate it very very much i also want
to invite you
to get a membership on my website we are
primarily funded by folks who grab
memberships on the website you know
youtube twitch all these different
platforms they take slices slices slices
when you get a membership on our website
we really keep almost everything um 2.9
percent we pay to swipe credit and debit
cards so it really is the top way to
support the work that we're doing and we
have this coupon code here felony 21. it
saves you a whole bunch of money i can't
even say how much my attorney says don't
don't mention it just say it's good but
don't say how much and i'll thank
everybody who does that everybody who
signs up on my website
uh very very much appreciate it um
what we were just looking at was was
this story a juror in the kyle
rittenhouse trial was dismissed for
joking about jacob blake that's the
video we were just seeing from yesterday
the juror
the juror a retired white man made the
joke to a court police officer as the
officer escorted him to his car on
wednesday afternoon the officer reported
the joke to judge bruce schroeder which
is the right thing for the officer to
have done and it didn't indeed lead to a
dismissal
uh which is the right thing that should
happen um
hard to disagree with that guys hard to
make the case that the juror should stay
very tough very tough to argue that
uh people are um asking if i've made up
my mind about the case well in a sense i
have i believe that um
kyle rittenhouse will be found not
guilty on the homicide charges and i
think it's totally plausible that he
will get a slap on the wrist for some of
the lesser charges
that's my assessment
now
when even when people say but david
um
do you think that he's not guilty in the
spirit of it
my view is that a 17 year old had no
business 17 year old from illinois had
no business being in kenosha wisconsin
at all it there's actually an element of
this that's reminiscent of the george
zimmerman case which is george zimmerman
um
caused the confrontation with trayvon
martin
who he ultimately killed and was found
not guilty due to self-defense
right
so
by the letter of the law
you have a very big hill to climb
in order to say that beyond any doubt it
was not self-defense when you have a
very muddled situation where people have
firearms and things are crazy and
there's protesters encounter protesters
and vigilantes and all these things so
by the standard of beyond a reasonable
doubt i think it will be really tough
to convince the jury
that there is no chance that this was
valid self-defense
shouldn't have been there
shouldn't have the gun
17 year old cape of the gun
created the confrontations by being
there
very conflicting evidence shown on the
videos where kyle rittenhouse is chasing
then he's being chased all these
different things but i think by the by
the letter of the self-defense statutes
it is
likely in my mind that kyle written
house will be found not guilty on those
um
there's people in the chat asking me
really stupid things that have no
bearing on what i'm actually saying and
criticizing me for things i've not said
and i'm not even gonna engage with that
it's just it's gutter trash
okay
he still bought the gun illegally and is
in possession of it he crossed state
lines without legal right to carry a gun
i agree yeah right so i think that's
going to be a real problem
i want to say thanks to blueberry babe
for gifting a subscription via twitch
number 12. i have the goal of getting
ourselves back to a thousand from the
standpoint of twitch uh subscription so
i really appreciate everybody uh
supporting us there
huge thank you to jacob steinberg jr
steinberg jr is interesting you don't
tend to see jewish folks do the junior
thing
but maybe jacob steinberg
is half jewish i don't know but jacob
steinberg jr thank you for signing up
with the coupon code felony21 on my
website
um
someone i actually trust is saying the
code isn't working let me just take a
look at it lots of times this is just to
goad me into this
let's see i say yearly
code
felony 21
it is working
it's working incredibly well look at
that that's a that's a shocking discount
i shouldn't shouldn't even be legal
could be a misdemeanor
let's see here coupon code
[Music]
yeah it's working fine guys please
please please please
um trial will will resume shortly yes if
you are just joining us but everything
working fine i want to say thanks to
lili mw lily mw who just subscribed via
twitch prime really appreciate that
um do i have any voicemails about the
trial that i don't know let me see what
we've got here
is a b-dog here
i got another question for you dog
um
recently republicans did very well in
the virginia election by using culture
wars virginia is uh culture was
something democrats can use to win
elections i actually addressed that on
my show today today
here's another troll
sir it's
true man the anti-intellectual
so i have two issues i'm going to keep
it concise
first i'm going to say well i apologize
you guys voicemail's two minutes long
offended by my last email or voicemail
excuse me
um
but anyway so two things number one
um
you think it's immoral for the
unvaccinated to choose not to get
vaccinated however what you don't find
it immoral that you fire them knowing
that there could be
children
in their household that are affected by
it so it's okay to make the children
suffer because of the parents and
ability or when women have to get
vaccinated dear god okay let's go now to
the eggman
hi dave this is completely serious okay
i have diagnosed the san antonio troll
the san antonio oh my god the troll from
texas okay here's the deal with this guy
okay
he is smoking uh pure sativa he needs an
indica okay
the problem is he's smoking weed that
makes your brain hear and see and do all
this crazy stuff right he needs an
indica which will slow down your brain
relax you and see things more clearly
okay
i right now i'm offering to kick him
like a jar like an ounce of some really
good uh
it's a strong indica right it's like a
multi-indica cross with a little bit of
sativa um it's a strain that i made
years ago i kind of call it pacman bud
it's really good right i want to give
him an ounce for free and to and after
like a couple weeks of that i want to
see if he's still hearing
insane things that you say that aren't
actually true um all right shalom
brother what the eggman's referring to
is that the san antonio troll called in
today and said david your take about
india walton is so stupid you think she
needed to go more socialist to win and
it's like i never said that wait that's
not my analysis of that
a big thank you to fonte
as well as amber amber wamber and just
here for kit
who just signed up via twitch prime we
love twitch prime also thanks to eric
green who just signed up on my website
with the coupon code
felony21 obama i very much appreciate
that um the code is the code is on fire
guys it's crazy let's get to some super
chats most juries for these types of
trials never look at the root cause of
the case and usually decide the way you
describe unfortunately right i guess
what i'm describing is sort of more of
like a jury nullification type of
of response
and i think you're right
the guy who was smoking a cigarette
while [ __ ] carrying two fire
extinguishers and where were their
medical supplies hmm
chef's pawns i do think kyle rittenhouse
had like a fanny pack with elements of
medical in it
if it was done on purpose it was smart
to make the witness show that tattoo on
his forearm i noticed that
this guy's an iraqi vet he was on a
documentary
david just tuning in are we watching a
video clip from the onion i know i know
they're going to say that because kyle
had full metal jacket rounds in his
ar-15 i'm assuming that he did not
intend on using it for self-defense
interesting
would you be a guest on ethan and
hassan's leftovers show gladly anytime
and marcus says david been a little
while since i tuned in killer stash my
man
yeah i'm doing i'm doing i'm trying it
out you know
uh it's it's re it started as a joke but
it's sort of taken a life of its own
i was actually
i'm gonna be honest i was thinking of
shaving it today after the stream
um
i guess maybe i could be convinced not
to oh wow people saying don't dare shave
it oh my god people saying don't shave
it
listen i'll tell you what uh if we get
to 50 website members i will keep it let
me see if i can do this now
um
let's see let me see if i can put here
stash
18 of 50. let me see if this works
no that didn't work
how was it there's a way to code that
oh i had a way of doing two things over
here
that's too bad
okay well in any case
it'll be 50 i'll keep it i'll keep it
for another day how about this if we get
to 50 i will even start extending it and
making it handlebar is that interesting
to people where over the next few days i
will i will let it go further and
further down without shaving and then
we'll see where we're at come
thanksgiving that doesn't seem like okay
people like that people like that all
right good okay
um
thank you for your time and information
kyle should not have been there period
that were you or me we would have gotten
no bail in the book thrown at us david
don't you dare hashtag team stash oh my
god
captain pollywog van der beef says very
strong stream sir yeah there everybody
relax we're not missing anything they're
starting back up in a few minutes
scheduled to start soon
i want to say a huge thank you to t ewin
woodruff who just made a pledge via
patreon here's an extra incentive
patreon counts double today so instead
of patreon putting us at 19
it puts us at 20. patreon counts double
uh thanks to sriman shari for signing up
on my website with the coupon code
felony21 very much appreciate that
you're too kind also thanks to ferret
chief and ares god of men for the twitch
prime subscriptions putting us at 23
m frazzled just gifted five
subscriptions on twitch which puts us at
28
which is extremely strong from the
standpoint of keeping the
mustache
um
yeah
kyle wasn't himself without a snickers
whoa
all right so they're about to get back
don't worry everybody we're not going to
lose track the deal is yeah 50 and i'll
keep the mustache rather than shaving it
today kyle's just having a really good
time at this thing huh
really seems to be enjoying himself
thanks to yerbik for the twitch prime
subscription number 29 today appreciate
it
welcome to
mo stash who just subscribed on my
website with the coupon code felony21
fake names related to mustaches always
welcome you can put any name you want
when you sign up on my website we don't
care
alexander hamilton
just got a twitch subscription number 31
today
thanks to steph wisco who just signed up
on my website using an old coupon code
sad trump from when it was like sad that
trump was a thing and it still is
um
the judge seems to have really powerful
indica i would agree with that yeah
that's a good point
marvin the mustache signing up very
exciting
uh the judge what is the judge snacking
on does anybody know
elements of walnuts yeah that could be
good afternoon folks again um by the way
how are the calzones
you're gonna be seated
oh my god were they uh anybody who
didn't like him
how about
the the staff down here eat all the
chips before i got any but
but
we have subway tomorrow
how were the calzones let's go subway
can you imagine
put it in the trash
um thank you to uh mazzak for gifting
five subs as well as maddie d for the
twitch prime sub
we're almost at me keeping the must the
mustache may live to see another day
real quick ernesto jimenez just signed
up on my website gloria byers just
signed up on my website and scott
faulkner did as well that puts us at 41.
at 50 the mustache survives if we don't
make it the mustache will be gone by
this time tomorrow um exhibit 11. this
is the corey elijah or corey washington
live stream we've got a pause here at uh
i believe that's the 54 minute and 30
second mark uh oh
be precise 54 29. do you see yourself in
this video oh boy i do okay um we're
gonna play this video forward for about
20 seconds and then we'll we'll pause
okay
big massive dumpster
[Applause]
[Music]
anybody else that said that there's
features
now
mr
bulch
what we've just seen in that video it
showed you
uh walking uh near the
the gas price uh electronic sign there
for the ultimate gas station uh would
you agree with me on that i would and
you appear at the end here to kind of
walk behind that uh hey guys i'm sorry
to interrupt but a viewer just recorded
on a different feed just now the the
judge was caught on a hot mic and
apparently he was complaining about how
long this was going on let's take a look
at this
[Music]
subway sandwiches
[Music]
[Music]
it seems like it's been
the josh is bored he wants it to end
[Laughter]
we had
oh man that is rich guys that is rich
all right let's get back to it
sir are we boring you your honor to go
north and that's when i heard a pistol
shot
and then almost immediately following it
i heard four
rifle shots
all right let's get back over here to
where they are uh
we're getting to the shooting so i think
we probably want this bearcats were
right here
when i got there a sheriff's deputy
held me over to the car
i met the bearcat he opened the door i
sat there and had a two to three minute
conversation with him maybe about what
was going on over there
at that point he directed me to go
behind the bearcats to go across the
street
so
at about that point
i moved west across
sheridan road
when i got there i turned to go north
and that's when i heard a pistol shot
and then almost immediately following it
i heard four
rifle shots
what did you do then
i turned and headed south
where did you go
um
towards where i heard the shooting
so
i was right around in here
and i ran across the street
into this green area here
telling everybody to get down
and then i got to the end
overlooking this area here there's like
a low wall
and then shooting
erupted
behind me over in this
general area
when you say this general area can you
um point the pointer at that again
please miss that
you're pointing to the area along
sheridan road south of 60th
sort of in front of the boost mobile and
check and go
correct
again we're going to try and play this
artificial
thought process right i know you
probably know now what that was but let
me just ask first of all
at the time
the shooting you just described at that
time that night did you know what was
going on i had no idea what was going on
with the benefit of hindsight and
watching all the other videos now what
what was that if you know
the first shooting that i heard the
pistol shot on the rifle shots
where is the engagement between the
defendant
and
rosenbaum
and the people that were with him down
here
the secondary shootings
would have been anthony huber and gage
gorowitz
is that gage grosskroit's coits yes it's
kind of a difficult name
can i just ask mr bulch when you were
where were you specifically
when you heard or observed the shootings
of mr huber and mr grosskroitz
um i didn't visually see them i heard
them okay
but i would have been
right in this area right here
do you know if the shootings of huber
and gross kreutz were
further north of where you were at on
sheridan or further south if you know it
sounded like they were coming from
behind me so they would have been to the
north okay
so
we're gonna have another video it's just
gonna take a second to set it up pretty
powerful video here
folks we're at 50 the mustache has
survived another day
the mustache will stay
i've i've just gotten a report from the
courtroom reportedly the calzones had no
fresh buffalo mozzarella they they're
giving out calzones with no fresh
buffalo mozzarella here hang a portion
at the end can we rewind just a little
bit from there please
keep going back
keep going back
keep going
all right play from there please
this is at the 43 second mark in the
video we've already had some testimony
about this video but um mr bulch
do you see anyone that you know in that
video
uh no
okay there's an individual there that
is standing there's two individuals that
i see on that screen the one on the
right
is kind of an all dark and appears to be
holding a rifle of some sort
uh do you know who that is yeah i have
no idea okay can we back that up again
about 10 seconds please and then we'll
play it forward
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
keep moving
[Applause]
mr bulge that would appear to be me
that's you isn't it yeah
you're actually at this point north
of where the huber and gross court
shootings occurred this could be pretty
yeah you didn't know where you were you
remember what you did
actually before i asked that question
we can see in this video
that the defendant kyle rittenhouse is
walking up the street after he has just
shot and killed anthony huber
and just shot gage gross crates in the
arm
at the time
i know with the benefit of hindsight
you've watched these things but at that
particular moment had you any idea
what had just happened
no
did you see those shootings
no
did you see the defendant
no
you've been
trained in the military been around
shootings before fair to say yes
how did
how is it possible that you didn't see
those things um i wasn't
looking down the street when it happened
did you hear those gunshots yes
did they draw your attention to that yes
did you look
yes
so how come you say you didn't see
um because by the time i got that far
close enough to see it everything was
done
did you see the bodies uh well the body
of mr huber yes
at what point
when you're
moving down the street did you see him
see that body um after
i got to gross coits
when i got down there jason linkowski
was helping
put a tourniquet on his arm
there's actually a video of that where i
come around the side and ask
everybody's all right if they got it
um
saw the wound on gross quote's arm
holy crap
and then i ran over to check anthony
hubert's body
when when we've played this video before
we've heard a lot of people's voices
shouting out about the defendant you
know that's the guy whatever things like
that did you hear any of those voices at
that time
i wasn't really trying to pay attention
to
what they were pointing out
when in this process did you realize
that an individual or individual's
people had been shot
um
well i heard the shooting so i knew that
there was shooting going on
i didn't know anybody had actually been
hit until i got to gross coits
is it fair to say that this wasn't the
first time all evening that you'd heard
gunshots
we'd heard them a couple times
throughout the night
when you would hear gunshots would you
wonder if that meant someone was injured
most of the time they were far enough in
the distance that
there would be very little impact from
us going in that direction
i think you testified earlier that what
originally started you heading south was
hearing the pistol shot and the four
shots that occurred at car source and
63rd correct and that according to the
map is about three blocks away
correct you talk about hearing other
gunshots that are in the distance
why did the shots here three blocks away
attract your attention when others did
not
um they were a lot closer than the other
ones had been
and there was the potential that
people that i was with that night were
down there
did you think to yourself
that's the defendant
no
you didn't know did you know where he
was at i didn't know where he was at but
i didn't assume who had been doing the
shooting
when we see you in this video
is that after you have
looked for the defendant yes
when we see you in this video did you
have any idea where the defendant was
no
when you when we see you in this video
had you
checked at ultimate gas to see if the
defendant was there
yes did you find him
no
when we see you in this video had you
already traveled north of the police
line at 60th yes
had you seen the defendant up there no
is it fair to say that at this moment in
the video you didn't have any idea where
the defendant was i had no idea where he
him or jason lukowski were
and even though he's walking up this
middle of the street
near where you're at at this point in
the video
you didn't see him
i didn't pay any attention to him now
who is the first
person who's shot by the defendant
that you went to
grow squids
did you help to treat him at all um i
made sure that they that lukowski had
everything under control
i saw that he had a handgun in his hand
um
i already knew that a pistol shot had
been fired and some rifle shots
i kind of assumed he was the person that
shot the right the pistol shot
um but as far as who had
shot him
i had no idea
in fact for a minute there i thought it
was lukowski
who had shot mr gross crates yeah
because he was already there
after you
dealt with mr grosskroitz what did you
do next
i ran over to anthony huber
tell us about that um he was
laying kind of slumped over in the
gutter a little bit there in the street
um there were a couple of protesters
kind of around him
when i ran up on him
they ran off
um
i started to roll him over check on him
put my hand on his neck to see if there
was a pulse or whatnot
and didn't feel one but it was
really just like a split second check
and then bearcat pulled up next
when you say bearcat you mean one of the
armored law enforcement vehicles and
what if anything did those folks do
um they climbed out
um
they told me they were going to take him
they were going to take him so i kind of
gathered up his stuff that was laying on
the ground
put it on him helped him load him up in
there
what did you do next um i continued
south
now i know you described what you've
done so far with mr huber uh
lying there
did mr huber say anything
uh mr huber was deceased as far as i'm
aware
so at the moment you came upon his body
he was already dead
so far as i know yes
and you said you continued south after
that correct where did you go i went to
the 63rd street location
what did you find when you were there um
on the way down
i heard
protesters saying somebody else had been
shot down there somebody else had been
shot down there
and i could hear shooting going on
at the 63rd street location
or thereabouts
this is what you do once you got to the
63rd location um once i got there i
somehow on the run picked up a couple of
folks associated with the protest who
were armed as well
mr lakowsky
came in not too soon after that
because you could hear the shooting
coming from
this area over here
and there were protesters kind of like
huddled over into here i just want to
make a record mr balch because um
we need to be able to have everything
typed in so if i could just describe
what you've just shown us and please
correct me if i'm wrong i think you had
pointed the pointer at the 63rd street
area
in the block
west of sheridan road between there and
is that 10th avenue
between sheridan and 10th avenue um is
that fair to say that's fair to say and
i know you indicated there was an area
where
did you say there were gunshots that you
heard coming from um yes can you again
point so i can make sure i am okay
you're you're describing the area that
is sort of the west half
of the block
between sheridan and 10th avenue along
63rd on the north side of 63rd is that
accurate that's accurate and you
indicated you heard some gunshots from
that area
yes do you remember how many
um there were quite a few
did you see anybody who was doing the
shooting i didn't visually see anybody
shooting
visually he didn't
auditory movies awesome
we moved into this
area right next to the building
i kind of popped around
into those cars
there were two or three cars over in
there
and
it looked like
this building right here was where it
was coming from
but there are also shots coming from
further back
okay and
if i could just please make a record of
all the things you just described you
indicated that you
were in the car source lot near the
building on the course of car source lot
and kind of looked around it is that
right correct would that have been a
long time there's a lot of confusion in
the chat this is a prosecution witness
i know it sounds like this is a law
enforcement guy he was he he
maybe sees himself that way but this was
a volunteer guard as it says on the
screen okay it's on the screen this is a
kenosha volunteer guard did you see
again or observe at that location
um it looked like somebody was
there was somebody standing
in the
second floor window
and they looked to be holding a gun
[Music]
to get a better look i kind of moved out
into the cars and faced in that
as soon as the person in the window saw
me they ducked around the corner
and then bullets started coming
from the west and started hitting the
car that i was hiding behind
the person you saw in in the window is
this a window of a house it looks like a
house yes this is someone inside a house
holding a firearm
they may or may not have been
and then bullets came from the west and
hit the vehicle that was near you
correct did any of those hit you no what
did you do as a result of that um
one of the folks associated with the
protest was behind a car with me
i told him to get behind the car source
building and we scooted around behind
the building real quick what happened
then
um
that that point there was a white car
that had caught on fire
the gas tank went off on it
kind of poked her heads back around by
that time swat was directly behind the
building from car source
and they're like hey somebody's over
here shoot
[Music]
that's fine let me let me um
skip ahead for a moment can we show
exhibit number 13
at the 2140 mark please
you had testified that when you went
down to the 63rd street location you saw
that plastic bag on the ground is that
right yes i'm gonna
have an image of that up on the screen
and i'd like you to take a look at that
when it's ready here
and why they are technically getting an
image up for the witness all right we'll
get back over to this other feed and
there seems to be these discussions
happening a lot i want to keep thanking
people who are subscribing today because
i really appreciate it ann
smeistrela oh boy i'm really struggling
with that has just signed up on my
website so has jason williamson that's a
name i'm very comfortable with the
pronunciation for because we did get to
50 i'm not shaving the mustache today uh
we got to i was threatening to but i'm
going to keep it
they are working here on different
technical elements as they continue to
be
also thanks to lil pablo mesa for the
twitch prime subscription i appreciate
that as well this is a prosecution
witness
being questioned by the prosecution this
is direct examination
um
the website is joinedpakman.com
joinpacman.com
mustache is fine
yeah i may go handlebar if we get to 100
we'll see
but the technical issues continue we did
have a video earlier the judge caught on
a hot mic complaining that the testimony
feels like it's been going on quote
forever
and that's going to be maybe something
that comes up i'm sam smith
mixed up there we're gonna uh
play a little bit of that video here i'd
like you to take a look at if you could
please thanks
all right guys so here's what we got
going on we are not trying to
to spook anyone or
we're going to move in it looks like god
that helps play the video please thanks
mr bulch there's an object on the ground
on the left side of this uh view screen
do you see that object yes can you
identify that for us oh that's the uh
plastic bag that i picked up to take a
look at
that's the one that mr rosenbaum threw
is that correct correct
a couple more things finally um after
all is said and done here
you
stayed at this location and spoke to
some individuals who were from the media
is that fair to say uh we kind of get
ambushed by them
well
make it sound like they were trying to
attack you they they came up and yeah
they came up out of nowhere and we
weren't expecting them when you say we
who was with you uh jason lekowski was
with
when they asked when these folks asked
you your name
what did you tell them i gave them a
false name of thomas craig why did you
do that to protect my identity so that i
could get out of there and figure out
what was going on
there were folks there that showed you
video
of
what happened that night yes
in those
view screens
were you able to see
the defendant
one of the
live streamers did show me a picture of
the defendant when he was laying on the
ground
being struck on the head and i believe
when he fired his weapon
from that were you able to identify that
that was someone that you had been with
yes that evening
did you admit that
to them no
in fact when they confronted you on it
and accused you of knowing exactly who
that was
you lied to them and told them you did
not correct correct
and when i
discussed this with you you gave me the
explanation that because you were
concerned for your safety at that time
um yeah we were surrounded by several
people
and there were groups of them milling
around
us as well
at that moment that you lied about
knowing the defendant you still had your
ar-15
correct correct and your glock
no i didn't have the glock at this time
and mr lukowski was with you yes was he
armed yes
were there police cars nearby
further down the street from us yes but
they were dealing with the shootings and
whatnot
once you
were informed
that the defendant was the one who had
been involved in these shootings was a
suspect
did you approach the police that night
and tell them about your information
no oh
i have nothing further
and i think they are doing this
leaving very little time
the defense may only have 15 to 30
minutes before they wrap
just just one second does anybody need a
break
go ahead
question that evening
while you were out on patrol
patrol my client kyle rittenhouse
you're armed he's armed
this is correct and you went by law
enforcement on numerous occasions
yes did anybody ever tell you
you can't be out there with these
weapons no did anybody ever question you
or him about your age no
you were interviewed several days
after this by the fbi correct correct
could this guy stand and talk into a mic
maybe
about that bag correct
correct
and
reading from the report
you told them
you examined the bag quickly and
observed an ammonia mixture and a small
bleach bottle correct correct
is that what you observed that's what i
thought it observed at the time i smell
uh i didn't check the smell okay
what made you think it was ammonia um
because of what we had been hit with
earlier in the night
and when the bomb had been hit earlier
in the night
mr rosenbaum was there with that bag
correct yes
you testified
that
when you wrote through that evening at
the end you didn't have your glock
correct correct you had borrowed it to
nick smith
he told me his name was nathan but yes
okay
so you were using a pseudonym false name
correct nathan was using a false name
yes
did he give you a false name or did he
say kyle rittenhouse i'm pointing to my
client
i don't remember if he gave me a
pseudonym or not he went by kyle most of
the night when he was talking to me kyle
yeah
you refer
to
a man and a woman
who you always saw with rosenbaum
correct correct can you describe that
man
uh he was tall scraggly looking with a
beard okay he had like camo shorts on
too i think okay okay let's switch over
here we do prefer this feed when we've
got it smith
he told me his name was nathan but yes
okay
so
you were using a pseudonym false name
correct nathan was using a false name
it's a little behind yeah
did he give you a false name or did he
say kyle rittenhouse i'm pointing to my
client
i don't remember if he gave me a
pseudonym or not he went by kyle most of
the night when he was talking to me kyle
yeah
you refer
to
a man and a woman
who you always saw with rosenbaum
correct
correct
can you describe that man uh he was tall
scraggly looking with a beard okay he
had like camo shorts on too i think okay
do you remember anything about the top
i can't remember the color of the top
specifically
yeah
do you remember anything specifically
about the woman
um she had a black backpack on she was
a little heavy set maybe do you remember
anything about her hair
um so would you call her thick bright
color maybe okay
i'll show you a picture see if you
recognize these individuals
sir i don't know
this is surreal
yeah
was that a burp did you guys just hear
that
did this guy just belch into the mic
what the hell was that
how does the court stenographer note
that
yeah this is a good super chat amazing
how this witness can give straight
answers now
[Applause]
folks the mustache does stay we did get
50 members at 100 it will be molded into
a handlebar starting today which will go
all right so the question asked by the
defense attorney mark richards was
whether or not he would recognize the
male and the female the man and the
woman that he saw with one of the
individuals who was shot and killed in
this case uh the judge is asked not to a
lot of characters straight out of
central casting here and bam and so he
said let me show you picture and see if
you can identify them and we can see
there's some technical issues along with
uh what he's trying to pull up
could you take a picture of my laptop
screen and then print the picture for
the defendant to look at please
associates
um computer do you recognize anybody in
that picture
um the female with the red hair the one
that was accompanying rose and bomb and
the other male okay the other male is
not in the picture completely
correct correct but that is the
individual who is with mr rosamond do
you notice anything in his hand he's got
the handgun in his hand as usual
as usual you might not be able to tell
see i did it for you with this bar right
here does that tell you where that was
that's at the ultimate gas station
[Applause]
sir did you find this woman attractive
that evening
and
you and my client were present when mr
rosenbaum
threatened you and kyle correct correct
and he specifically said if he got
either of you alone
he would expletive kill you that's
correct
any doubt about that
no doubt about that told the fbi that
yes and that was right after
um
i'm gonna get his name wrong
dustin had put out dumpster fire correct
it was about 20 to 30 minutes before we
headed south and the shooting started
and
mr binger asked you some questions about
did he try to attack you at that time
how many guys
were there
there were about four or five armed men
in front of him okay and there's some
other iron man on the roof correct
that were upsetting him because he
he seemed to not appreciate armed men
okay and you specifically referred to
him
and i wrote the words down
he was a hyper aggressive individual
correct that is correct tell me what
that means to you
um every encounter i saw him have with
someone was extremely aggressive
you saw him lighting fires lighting
fires
getting in people's faces
protesters and armed individuals were
having to get between him and other
people
to stop fights from happening did you
see him tip over the porta potty
um i didn't witness that okay did you
see him
take rocks out of the saint james rock
pile
uh he got the rocks he was throwing from
somewhere was he collecting his own
urine during the evening then taking the
trailer out of st james taking it down
the road and starting it on fire i
didn't witness that event i have nothing
further thank you sir no problem
couple things uh mr polish and then
we'll be done
you testified you gave a statement to
the fbi correct
that was uh dated
august 28th of 2020 would it sound right
to you
yes that sounds correct three days after
this incident that is correct
when you spoke to the fbi
what was your intent
um
well i really didn't have any intentions
of speaking to the fbi they just showed
up at the house
i gave them what information i could
remember and what i could make sense of
they were very clear with me to only
give them the information that i was 100
sure about
did you withhold any information from
them no
did you
tell them the truth yes
were
events
in your mind clearer
three days after the incident than they
might be now
um
even then it was
the whole situation was kind of a big
jumble
and i was trying to put timelines
together
so i had told them explicitly that my
timelines are going to be a little off
i understand that but
do you think your memory of what
happened on the night of august 25th was
better
three days later than it is 14 months
later it would be yes
when you spoke to the fbi did they
identify themselves as the fbi yes
did you know you're speaking to law
enforcement officials yes
did you understand that if you
didn't tell them the truth that that
could get you in trouble yes and you
wanted to be completely honest with them
yes
did you understand that they were asking
you questions about a homicide yes
did you understand that you
that it would be
helpful to give them as much information
as possible about what happened here yes
was that what you wanted to do yes did
you want to cooperate with them yes did
you want to tell them everything that
you knew about what happened yes
in your statement
you say and i'm going to quote
this is on page three of your statement
balch stated that this eventual victim
who's joseph rosenbaum was carrying a
hospital style bag with chemicals to
make molotov cocktails
you then say later on that you
this is on page four balch examined the
bag quickly and observed an ammonium
mixture and a small bleach bottle
first of all is that am i reading your
statement to the fbi correctly you are
none of that is true
is it
it doesn't appear to be no
nowhere
in this statement to the fbi did you
mention any tall guy with a scraggly bur
uh beard or a shorter woman with
colored hair correct correct
nothing further
now he really remembers exactly who they
were
no they just never ask those questions
correct me if i'm wrong but when the fbi
talks to you
they don't write out a statement for you
let you review it for accuracy and
completeness do they
no they just ask you questions they show
up to your house on announce you answer
the questions they leave and they write
down what they think is important that
is correct i have nothing further my boy
okay folks let's break for the day and
uh please uh call after a student
report is gonna be down here in a few
minutes okay uh
i'm thinking about my monday juries when
we finish with a um please um uh don't
talk about the case read watch or listen
on the account of the trial
and are they not sequestered i'll turn
you over to uh
the clerk of the court and um
i think she could probably take care of
it here in the library maybe
or maybe they want to go upstairs anyway
you have things upstairs
tomorrow we'll have meatball grinders
from subway
go out there and see you there thanks
see you see you tomorrow
[Applause]
jury exiting
[Music]
[Music]
a big thank you to danny coradine jones
who just grabbed a membership on my
website joinedpakman.com
[Music]
quite a day here quite a day
well it's the conclusion of all right
let's see if there's still got stuff
going no that's gonna that's basically
it looks like that's it yeah
all right guys that's the conclusion for
today oh no we're back live hold on
so the jury's not sequestered and
written house is out on bail right i
mean that's what's going on
okay now it does seem to actually be
over
um all right everybody i appreciate
everybody who joined me today uh we will
likely be back virginia
new jersey oh my god
we will likely be back with more
coverage tomorrow
thanks to everybody who supported the
stream
see everybody very very soon please
proceed governor thank
you you